In the last video, I started
with this matrix right here,
and right from the get go, we
said the span of this matrix
is just the span of the column
vectors of it, and I just
wrote it right there.
But we weren't clear whether
this was linearly independent,
and if it's not linearly
independent, it won't be a
sufficient basis.
And then we go off and
we figure out the
null space of A.
We find out that the null space
of A contains more than
just the zero vector.
It's just the span of these two
vectors here, which means
that these columns are not
linearly independent.
We saw that several
videos ago.
And we used that information
that they're not linearly
independent to try to make them
linearly independent by
getting rid of the
redundant ones.
So we were able to get rid of
this guy and this guy, because
these were essentially the
columns associated with the
free variables.
And we were able to do it using
this little technique
down here, where we set one of
these equal to 0, the other
one equal to negative
1 and then solved
for the pivot variables.
And then we set the other one
equal to 0 and the other one
equal to negative 1 and solved
for the pivot variables.
And you could imagine
that this is a
generalizable process.
If you have a bunch of free
variables, you can set all of
them but one to equal 0, and
then that one that you didn't
set to 0, you set it to
equal negative 1.
And you can express it as a sum
of the pivot variables,
where the pivot variables are a
function of the free variables.
In general, this would be
a quick way of doing it.
We had to do it more
slowly over here.
If I have some matrix A, and I
want to figure out the basis
for the column space, the column
space is just the span
of these, but if I wanted a
linearly independent basis, I
need to figure out some set
of these that are linearly
independent.
What I can do is put this guy
into reduced row echelon form.
When I put them in reduced row
echelon form, and I did that
over here, this is the reduced
row echelon form of A, I can
look at the variables
that are associated
with the pivot entries.
So this is x1.
Let me scroll up a little bit.
This is associated
with x1, right?
When you multiply this times x1,
you get this column times
x1, this column times x2, this
column times x3, this column
times x4 like that.
When you look at just regular A,
when you look at just your
matrix A, it's the same thing.
If you were to write Ax equal
to 0, this column would be
associated with x1, this column
would be associated
with x2, x3 and x4 like that.
What you can do is you put it
in reduced row echelon form.
You say which columns have
my pivot entries or are
associated with pivot
variables?
You say, OK, x1 and x2 are
associated with pivot
variables, or they are the pivot
variables, and they're
associated with these first
two columns, and so those
first two columns would be a
basis for the column space.
How did I get this?
Am I just making up
things on the fly?
Well, no!
It all comes from the reality
that you can always construct
a situation where the vectors
associated with the free
variables you can write them as
linear combinations of the
vectors associated with the
pivot variables, and we did a
special case of that
last time.
But a very quick and dirty way
of doing it, and I don't know
if it's actually dirty, is just
take your matrix, put it
in it reduced row echelon form,
and you say, look, this
column and this column
are associated
with my free variables.
Therefore, this column and this
column must be associated
with my free variables.
The solution sets are the same
to Ax equal to 0 or the
reduced row echelon form
of Ax is equal to 0.
So they're the same.
So if this column and this
column are associated with
free variables, so are this
column and this column, which
means that they can be expressed
just by judiciously
selecting your values of your
free variables as linear
combinations of the columns
associated with the pivot
variables, with the pivot
entries, which are that column
and that column.
So this column and this column
would be a basis for
A, and we see that.
We see that all the
way down here.
1, 2, 3 and 1, 1, 4, We did a
lot of work and we got all the
way there, and we said this
is a basis for the
column span of A.
Now, doing all of that work,
let's see if we can actually
visualize what the column
space of A looks like.
I have a strange feeling I might
have said column span a
couple of times, but the
column space, what
does it look like?
Well, there's a couple of
ways to think about
what it looks like.
One way is we can say, look,
this span this is 2-- that's a
member of R3.
That's a vector in R3 and
this is a vector in R3.
Let me draw my x, z and-- well,
normally it's drawn--
this is normally y, x, and
z-axes in R3, if I'm want to
represent them as
three-dimensional space.
Then the vector 1, 2, 3 might
look like this where it's one,
one, two, one, two, three,
so we go out one down
here, then up three.
So the vector will look like
that in its standard form.
That's that one right there.
And the vector 1, 1, 4 would be
one, one and go up four, so
it might look something
like this.
It's hard to actually draw
them very well in three
dimensions, but you
get the idea.
But the column space is the span
of these, so all of the
linear combinations
of these two guys.
So all of the linear
combinations of these two guys
are going to create
a plane that
contains these two vectors.
If you just sum these guys up in
multiple combinations, you
can get any vector up there.
If you just add them
up, you'll get that
vector right there.
If you add this guy plus 2 times
that, you'll get some
vector up here.
So if you view them as position
vectors, they'll
essentially form
a plane in R3.
But let's see if we can get the
equation for that plane.
Well, how can we do that?
Well, we know that we can figure
out the equation of a
plane based on the fact that
a normal vector dotted with
any-- let me write my normal
vector like this.
The normal vector dotted with
any position vector specifying
a position on the plane.
So let me call that x minus any
point on the plane or any
vector position on the plane.
So I could do that minus
the vector 1, 2, 3 has
to be equal to 0.
And we can use this information
to figure out the
equation for this plane.
But what is a normal vector?
How can we find a normal
vector to this plane?
So this would be a vector.
Let me see if I can draw
this in a way that
doesn't confuse the issue.
If the plane is like that,
the normal vector would
come out like that.
So how can I create
a normal vector?
Well, we learned that you take
the cross product of any two
vectors in R3, and the cross
product I've only defined so
far in R3, and I will get a
vector that's normal to both
of those vectors.
So let's take the
cross product.
This is a nice way of thinking
about it, because it's really
integrating everything that
we've covered so far.
So let me define my normal
vector to be equal to 1, 2, 3
cross 1, 1, 4.
And what does this equal?
So my first term,
I ignore that.
I get 2 times 4 minus
3 times 1.
2 times 4 is 8.
2 times 4 minus 3 times 1.
8 minus 3.
Then for my second row, I have
1 times 4, and my temptation
is do 1 times 4 minus
3 times 1.
But you reverse it.
You do 3 times 1, so it's
3, minus 1 times 4.
We've done that multiple
times.
You might want to review the
cross product video if that
seems strange.
You ignore the middle row, and
you normally do 1 times 4
minus 3 times 1, but the
middle row you switch.
We're only defining it for R3,
so instead, we do 3 times 1
minus 1 times 4.
And then finally for the last
row, we ignore it, and we say
1 times 1, which is 1, minus 2
times 1, which is minus 2.
And this is equal to the vector
5, minus 1, minus 1,
which by definition of the cross
product, and I've shown
this to you multiple times,
is normal to both of these
vectors, and so it'll be
normal to any linear
combination of these
two vectors.
So now that we have our normal
vector, we can define the
traditional equation
for the plane.
So we now know that our normal
vector 5, minus 1, minus 1,
that I got by taking the cross
product of our basis vectors
dot any vector in our plane.
So let me just write
any vector.
Let me just write it x, y, z.
So x, y, z since that's how
I defined my axes up here.
This was the x-axis.
x, y and z.
x, y, z minus-- I just
picked one of these.
I could have picked either of
them-- minus 1, 2, 3 has got
to be equal to 0.
So what's this?
This is going to be equal to--
let me write it a little
smaller, a little neater-- 5,
minus 1, minus 1 dot-- what's
this guy going to be?
x minus 1, y minus 2, and
z minus 3 has got
to be equal to 0.
And what's the dot product?
It's 5 times x minus 1 plus-- or
maybe I should say minus 1,
so it's plus minus 1 times y
minus 2 plus minus 1 times z
minus 3 is equal to 0.
That's just the definition
of our dot product.
If I simplify this, I get 5x
minus 5 minus y plus 2 minus z
plus 3 is equal to 0.
You have 2 plus 3 is 5 minus
5, so those all cancel out.
Those will equal 0.
And we get 5x minus y minus
z is equal to 0.
This plane in R3 is the
column space of A.
So we've now shown you that
it's truly a plane in A.
And actually, it makes
sense that this plane
intersects the origin.
If you set x, y, and
z equal to 0, it
satisfies this equation.
And that makes sense, because we
said that a column space of
a matrix has to be a valid
subspace, and a valid subspace
has to contain the
zero vector.
And in R3 that's the
coordinate 0, 0, 0.
Now, what I want to do now is
see if we can get at the same
answer going a completely
different way, or approaching
it in a completely
different way.
Let me get my original A,
which I've forgotten.
I've marked it up a good
bit, but let me just
copy and paste it.
So that's my original
A right there.
Let me copy it.
Let me paste it.
Nope.
That's not what I
wanted to do.
Let's see, so my original
A-- I copied and
pasted the wrong thing.
Let me do it a little-- don't
want to waste your time.
Edit, copy, edit, paste.
There you go and let me scroll
this down and get to a point
that's relatively clean.
Bring my A down.
I've used a lot of space.
So here you go.
This is my original
A right there.
And what I want to do is see
if I can get this result
completely different.
I got this result by figuring
out the basis of the column
span, finding a normal vector by
taking the cross product of
our two basis vectors, and then
using the dot product of
the normal vector with the
difference-- this vector right
here, where you take any vector
on our plane minus one
of our basis vectors,
that's to find some
vector in the plane.
This is some vector
in the plane.
So any vector in the plane
dotted with my normal vector
is going to be equal to 0.
And actually, I should probably
make a side note
here, that the only reason I
was able to say that the
normal vector is a cross
product of my two basis
vectors, is because I knew that
these two basis vectors,
not only do they specify some
point on the plane-- so let's
say that this guy right here
is this blue vector.
Not only does he specify some
point on the plane right
there, but the vector lies
completely on the plane.
How did I know that?
Because I knew from the get go
that the 0, 0 vector is in my
span, right?
I knew that if I draw this guy
in just standard position, the
point 0, 0, 0, is in my span,
and I know its end point is in
the span, so this whole vector
has to be in my plane, and
likewise, this whole vector
has to be in my plane.
So if I take the cross product,
anything normal to
these guys or any combination
of these guys is going be
normal to the plane, and we got
this result right here.
But let me take this right
here and use our other
definition of column span.
Our other definition, or it's
really an equivalent
definition, is all of the valid
solutions to Ax where x
is a member of Rn.
Or another way we could think of
it is, we could view it as
all of the valid b's where Ax
is equal to b, and x is a
member of Rn.
These are equivalent
statements.
I'm just defining b here to be
Ax, so these are equivalent
statements.
But let's run with this
a little bit.
So let's say that I define my
b, so b is going to be a
vector in R3, right?
We already have an intuition
like that.
When I take Ax, I get a b
that's equal to x, y, z.
And I want to figure out what x,
y's and z's can I get valid
solutions for?
So if I take my vector A and
then let me multiply it
times-- well, actually, the
best way to do it, I think
we're used to it right now.
If I'm solving the equation
Ax is equal to b, I can
essentially just create the
augmented matrix, where I have
the matrix A and I can augment
it with b, and put this in
reduced row echelon form, and
that'll essentially represent
the solution set.
So let me do that.
So if I just augment this matrix
right here with b, so I
write x, y, z.
So this is A augmented with b.
This is A, this is b.
let me put this in reduced row
echelon form and find the
solution set.
And these are x, y, and z's
that define a valid b.
So what do I get?
The first thing I want to do,
and we've done this exercise
before, let's keep my
first row the same.
1, 1, 1, 1, and I get an x.
And let's replace our second row
with the second row minus
the first row.
Actually let me do
it this way.
Let me replace the second row
with 2 times the first row
minus the second row.
So 2 times the first row minus
the second row, we're going to
get a 2x minus y up there.
And then 2 times
1 minus 2 is 0.
2 times 1 minus 1 is 1.
2 times 1 minus 4 is minus 2.
2 times 1 minus 3 is minus 1.
Fair enough.
And now let me replace my third
row with the third row
minus 3 times the first row.
So we're going to do the third
row minus-- no, let
me do it this way.
It's the third row minus
3 times the first row.
So I'm just doing the b column
first, because I can remember
what I did.
The third row minus 3
times the first row.
3 minus 3 times 1 is 0.
4 minus 3 times 1 is 1.
1 minus 3 times 1 is minus 2.
And then 2 minus 3 times
1 is minus 1.
Now, I could go all the way to
reduced row echelon form, but
something interesting is
already happening.
So let me from the get go try
to zero out this third row.
And the best way to zero out
this third row is to just
replace the third row.
So the first row-- well,
I won't even
write the first row.
The second row is 0, 1, minus
2, minus 1, and 2x minus y.
I'm not even going to worry
about the first row right now.
But let's replace the third row,
just in our attempt to go
into reduced row echelon form.
Let's replace it with
the second row
minus the third row.
So you get 2x minus
y minus z plus 3x.
I just took this minus this.
So minus z plus 3x.
So 0 minus 0 is 0.
1 minus 1 is 0.
Minus 2 minus minus 2 is
0, and that's also 0.
So we're only going to have a
valid solution to Ax equals b
if this guy right here
is equal to 0.
What happens if he's
not equal to zero?
Then we're going to have a bunch
of zeroes equaling some
number, which tells us that
there's no solution.
So if I pick a b where this guy
does not equal zero, then
I'll have no solution.
If this guy equals 5, if I pick
x, y, and z's such as
that this expression is equal to
5, then Ax equal to b will
have no solution, because it
will have 0 is equal to 5.
So this has to equal 0.
So 2x minus y minus z plus 3x
must be equal to 0 in order
for b to be valid, in order for
b to be a member of the
column space of A, in order for
it to be a valid vector
that Ax can become, or the
product A times x can become
for some x.
So what does this equal to?
If we add the 2x plus the 3x,
I get 5x minus y minus z is
equal to 0, which is the exact
same outcome we got when we
figured out the basis vectors.
We said oh, you know what?
The basis vectors, they have
to be in the column space
themselves by definition.
So let me find a normal vector
to them both by taking the
cross product.
I did that, and I said the cross
product times any valid
vector in our space minus one of
the basis vectors has to be
equal to zero, and then
I got this equation.
Or we could have done
it the other way.
We could've actually literally
solved this equation setting
our b equal to this.
We said what b's will give
us a valid solution?
And our only valid solution will
be obtained when this guy
has to be equal to zero, because
the rest of his row
became zero.
And when we set that equal
to zero, we got
the exact same equation.
So, hopefully, you found this
to be mildly satisfying,
because we were able to tackle
the same problem from two
different directions and get the
same result, and it kind
of shows you the beauty of
linear algebra, how it all
starts to fit together.